salut aujourd'hui je suis dans les loges
du grand point virgule pour les
hallucinations collectives et il ya
karim duval qui n'est pas programmé qui
est passé d'ailleurs tu viendras quand
tu le savais représentation la présence
de jean viard tout comme hier fernand si
tu nous écoutes ça veut dire faire nous
on ne risque rien j'ai beaucoup de
chance que carey me soit là parce que il
part au maroc dans pas longtemps pour
jouer comment s'appelle cette grande
salle où tu vas mégarama mais les
regarde jamais il ya un méga date c'est
une mégane alger ganamé gaza qui est
d'ailleurs celle des blancs qui étaient
mes gars et ça va être méga bien
dépenses ou femmes c'est bayrou et quand
je parle aux gens du club et franck
hausse nos marocains c'est ça c'est ça
puisque j'étais un peu français un peu
marocain et un peu sinon absolument
c'est ça n'a pas besoin de ça pour six
mois j'ai cherché quelque chose qui
s'applique est le plus à toi j'ai pas
trouvé de choses en chinois mais j'ai
trouvé par contre un recueil de poèmes
japonais ces proverbes ou sur celle et
voilà c'est la fin de course est très
épuré si tu pouvais lire le premier le
deuxième peut-être parce que mettant
japonais genou promis les japonais
mettent à les traductions après on peut
je vous le fais voir parfum d'une
chevelure qui nous submerge cours des
recherches toujours le maire dans ce
genre de faire la leçon mais ni fard la
grenouille saute d'un gros nuages c'est
joli ça il ya un sujet verbe complément
et ça me plaît je veux le sens par
contre tu avais la chance à barbe on
l'appliqué à la vie en fait et les
simpson ne diffèrent que par exemple des
fois tu peux te leur est en fait tu
crois que le ciel il a apporté en fait
c'est le reflet de ciel dans l'eau c'est
vrai et du gym vraiment premier elle
souhaite en fait elle veut sauter elle
veut atteindre un objectif trop et elle
tombe dans l'eau en fête
donc il faut peut-être réglé couloir par
chacun interprète peur qu'en fait c'est
un peu moi qui ont envie de faire le
mégarama et qui les chevauchements et un
grand bonjour positif parce que c'est
l'une des meilleures celles ouvertes de
paris perd à lembras françoise tu vas
ouvrir sur la page que tu veux tu vas
faire ton poème lui dis de manière à ce
que je puisse pas voir mais on va voir
comme ça dans la gopro en temps réel
d'agents ils pourront voir contraint de
montage
ok j'ai une clause et vidéos
ces bons tempère si tout le monde y aura
retenu à gaza où quelque part c'est bon
c'est bon ok on a vu come back à
grenouilles le nuage ce genre de choses
on peut visualiser ces scènes là en
temps normal on peut s'imaginer les
cheveux on peut s'imaginer la grenouille
le nuage la taxe est ce que toi ton
poème tu peux te le représenter en
termes d'image mentalement oui oui alors
pour représenter ces images là dans ta
tête
je vais essayer moi de symboliser sa de
dessiner ça ça me tape le hockey était
déjà allé chercher des choses en hauteur
donc je suppose qu'il ya vraiment un ou
un ciel est un bar très caméléon
ok maintenant reste à savoir si c'est le
jour la nuit ce genre de choses est
apparemment la nuit
comme ça c'est sûr qu'en espagnol
mondiale diablo parce que non en espagne
en 2001 rare maintenant la rime
mais il ya le dire et de dallas est sûr
c'est qu'il dit pour le développeur
je pense avoir le haut essaye de bien
représenter ce qui se passe en bas que
l'on regarde c'est ça ouais je vais
confier le choix de la tête quand c'est
bon c'est bon c'est bon là tu t'imagines
ski en bas est ce que tu peux imaginer
tant dessin ce que tu te représente
mentalement devant moi et bouger tes
yeux pour respecter tout ce qu'il ya
peut-être que écoute je vais faire un
dessin comme ça je dessine extrême prend
pas dans le tome i nobody des modèles
ok j'ai un dessin ne le changerai plus
regardent par là parce que je veux leur
faire voir à l'écran et je veux pas que
tu puisses nombreux regards d'ici leur
faire voir et je veux pas que tu puisses
toit voir ce que j'aime parce que j'ai
lu est ce que tu peux nous lire ton
poème maintenant la lune flottent au
dessus du cercle des danseurs alors je
dessine comme je peux mais j'ai décelé
la mine qui flotte au-dessus d'un arc de
danseurs gérer voire cancérigènes et il
a mille étoiles dimanche
vous aimez les toits du maroc et si on
suit la route on peut aller au giga rama
mécringes égal c'est pour la wii mais
gaffe mais pour le lendemain et met dans
la bouche le voir comme un qui se posent
la question après c'était la bei
ouvrière rejoint la fleur pour me2 et
chercher pour lequel ce dessin là
n'aurait pas marché du tout évidemment
bien sûr je suis bluffé tout en bleu
fait même quand je t'ai dit bonjour je
suis le fait au nom à retenir
je sais qu'il me revient à chaque fois
je reconnais que nous dans tous les
jours à chaque fois et ça jusque là mais
ce tour là je le maîtrise et salue karim
ça va j'ai mangé mortellement venir
voire au maroc mon pote j'aime bien sûr
une vidéo là bas mais oui je trouve un
budget blog au maroc eh ben on se cotise
et au 3 mars à ce parti ou pour fabien
olicard et et je prie pour que fabien
viennent jouer chez vous au maroc il va
tous vous bluffez il est énorme
vous donnez moi je jouais en algérie
mais bientôt en algérie pas coûte un pur
algérie l'ouest pas très beau festival
aussi que l'iran joue à nier karim sur
son facebook sur son site internet à
toutes les infos et il va sortir des
vidéos dans pas très longtemps j'ai vu
les roches enfin j'ai eu le titre
enfin il met à parler du concept est
vraiment je l'aurais on en a vachement
dit aux gens à propos de vidéos fait
avant l'alcool 1 comme ça ben tiens à
donner toute l'information s'ils sont
peu mentalist qui suivent sont grands et
mon blog et qui est qu'ils écoutent les
conseils étaient qu'ils arriveront en 2
min de quoi parle bien sûr imagine c'est
facile là je redis par mois l'évidence
aujourd'hui ouvrir une ère de mentalisme
non non surtout pas penser à vous
abonner abonnez vous à cette chaîne
youtube c'est hyper important vous
pouvez partager la vidéo
n'oubliez pas l'objectif à 2500 abonnés
on se fait un apéro virtuel tous
ensemble et rendez vous demain à 11h
pour prochain mentale vlog ciao